my hair is astonishingly incredibly
unbelievably red it is so cool and I
love it I just went down today and I got
it all done when I went in I didn't know
how it was gonna turn out my scalp is
still a little red you can see but they
had to bleach out all the blue and the
purple the purple was actually just a
result of the pool by the way I didn't
intentionally do that we look really
cool but I love this red I really have
no other point of this video than just
to show off my really cool red hair and
get you guys his opinion on it because I
really do value what you like but I love
this shade of red it's so cool and
finally like my channel color kind of
matches because if you guys have noticed
my channel icon has been red for years
for four years my channel icon has been
red and I mean the pink mustache is one
thing but now it's actually fully red
it's gloriously red it's so cool I'm
sorry I'm just really excited about it
and it's just I've been doing nothing
but taking a bunch of selfies like a
pretentious douche that I am and just
posting them everywhere on the internet
because like I said I'm a pretentious
douche and also I haven't made a video
do you know just like talk to you guys
or anything I mean this video is coming
up obviously way late at night it's not
on a regularly scheduled video so it's
not replacing anything there's still
gonna be two videos tomorrow but you
know I just haven't done a video just to
say hi to you guys in a long time so hi
how's it going it's going well in my
life I mean there's a lot of things that
I'm working on obviously me and the boys
are living out our lives and doing our
thing you know improv is a big thing in
my life right now and I'm trying to I'm
trying to be funnier I'm trying to be
funnier and you'd be surprised how hard
that is but you know part of what I do
here is just trying to be funny and
trying to entertain you guys and trying
to make you laugh so it's very important
that I try to study on how to be good at
that and you'd be surprised you'd think
that it'd just be an innate thing but no
there's a lot to learn about comedy and
like the timing of it and the
development of it and I've been going
out and seeing a bunch of shows and you
know everything's been going pretty good
in life and and
I really have no complaints at all
because I got a lot of things that you
know are going well for me and I'm
getting back into the roots of what I'm
doing here on YouTube you know I'm
making videos because I love making
videos and I've dipped my hand back in
making thumbnails again I don't know if
you guys have noticed but I've really
been working hard on that and I've just
been really working hard on trying to
make my videos better and better and
just getting back to like the base of
what I've been doing here since the
beginning you know the charity
livestreams what you're gonna be doing
this month the only problem is I have a
friend's wedding
on the 19th exactly on the 19th so it'll
probably be moved to March 26 is when
the livestream is going to be unless
something gets in the way which I don't
think it will but I have to go back to
Cincinnati for a friend's wedding
on the 19th but other than that yeah
it's just been very much focusing on
everything you know that makes this
something special and you know trying to
talk with you guys more and being
involved with comments and replying and
reading when I can't reply and it's been
really good because I feel a lot more
connected than I have in the past I've
been distracted by a lot of things that
have happened over the past year and a
lot of good and bad and you know things
that I needed to go like overcome and
get over but now it's finally you know
it's getting to the point where I'm
really happy like I'm really happy with
what we have and I'm really happy with
what I've been able to do and I'm really
happy that I'm able to play around with
stuff like this and it actually doesn't
turn out horrible for me and I think I'm
gonna stick with red for a while I think
this bright red is really working for me
I love it I mean I love the pink I love
the blue but I love the red it is so
cool other than that you know I I really
don't have anything that I wanted to
discuss besides it so normal videos will
occur tomorrow I just wanted to say hi
and you know say thank you again like I
usually do but you know I really do mean
it just thank you guys so much for being
here and being so supportive of what
we've been doing and and what I've been
doing you know not just what we've been
what I've been you guys have been so
supportive of me you guys are there for
me and my friends and what we do you
guys are supportive of it and that's
important that is super duper important
and I want to make sure that I return
the favor with the videos that I do
even though you know this isn't there's
literally no point to this video there's
no point in this video I just wanted to
show off my amazing hair but that is
part of what makes it so cool and makes
what I do here on YouTube so rewarding
so fulfilling so I'll I'll leave now
I'll show off my hair a little bit more
but I'll let you guys get on with your
night so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you guys so much for
being supportive of my utter crap that I
put out and thank you again everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye bye oh
nice